[Music]
to see those few moments of my life
seconds of my life I both laugh I almost
cry I'd lie to say that I went without a
thought that maybe it would come to me
but it was a pretty illustrious crew of
women I was nominated with Melissa Leo
the
final to work opposite Christian Bale
and Mark Walberg without mark we would
add a movie you know and if I could have
remembered all the names of all the crew
that's how we do what we do first and
foremost thank you Academy because it's
about selling Motion Pictures and
respecting the work thank you so
much to go back and look at it it really
reminds me what a turning point in my
life it was